people call me excess it's a nickname
you gave me when I was a kid and kind of
stuck here now
so anybody know what to do I'm sorry and
we can't let this get any worse I don't
have a suit actually I have a backup
total fan favorite hey everybody is
Charlie happy Comic Con week is still
going on there's still Comic Con stuff
happening at the season 5 panel the
producers started talking about the
hundredth episode what it was going to
be how it was gonna be this love letter
to comic book fans there's some pretty
easy predictions to make based on the
comic book stuff in the themes of season
5 that they talked about so we got to
break it down if your brain into the
channel there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so
structurally they've changed the way
that they plotted the season out
normally the crossover is episode 8 but
because episode 8 this year is gonna be
the Flash's hundredth episode these
special requested that all the shows
push the crossover to episode 9 which is
traditionally the mid-season finale
which is usually where you pay off big
storylines on each of the shows so what
they're doing now is this episode 9 of
all the shows will be Batwoman crossover
but also teasers for the second halves
of all the different seasons so it's
gonna feel a lot crazier but episode 100
of the flash is meant to be a love
letter to comic book fans and pay off a
lot of big things that they set up going
all the way back to the first season so
you'll see this as I go through my top
five predictions some of these are
pretty easy to guess so here we go top
five early predictions number five the
episode will be all about the legacy of
the flash family the entire flash family
the theme of season five / the producers
is legacy just in general as in Barry's
legacy as the flash Nora as the flash of
the future being Barry's literal legacy
and that she's his daughter and in a
broader sense the other members of the
flash family so number four with that in
mind we'll probably get a vision of what
things are like in the time period that
Nora came from it sounds pretty bad
based on what she said they already
confirmed that she's from 30 years in
the future so we'll call that 2048
because it's 2018 this year not too far
away from the 2056 future Barry message
from legends of tomorrow and also very
similar to the time period that Tsar II
came from when
humans have been outlawed she's also
from the 2040s so number three they'll
probably finally pay off the flash
Museum teaser from the season 1 finale
so remember season 5 all about legacy
there's a good part to that in a bad
part to that like the flash causes a lot
of collateral damage I'll talk about
that in a second but he also does a lot
of good things and the flash Museum
usually reflects that like these are all
the good things you've done these are
all the cool adventures that you've had
we even saw a building during season 3
from the outside and present-day that
looks very similar to the facade of this
building in the flash teaser so we don't
know if they had that in mind when they
did this during season 1 but remember
how HR wanted to make the STAR Labs
museum during season 3 think of that as
the precursor to a full-blown flash
museum we just haven't got there yet a
lot of the things that you would put in
the flash museum the other members of
the flash family the villains the
weapons like Captain colds gun most of
the big stuff you would put in there
there's a lot of those big adventures he
hasn't had yet so it was just a question
of how many seasons would go by before
they started to build the actual flash
museum but we're nowhere comes from 30
plus years in the future it probably
already exists so number two if we do
get flash museum this is actually you
know fan favorite I've been asking for
it for a while we'll also probably get
to see a version of John Wesley Shipp in
the 90s flash costume
we got a teaser for that when he was
crossing over to earth too during season
two but that implied that there was
another earth out there with a version
of Barry Allen that looked like John
Wesley Shipp that were a costume like
this within the logic of the show you
can either say that our version of jay
garrick from earth 3 wore this costume
when he was Barry Allen's age a long
time ago or they could just say that
this was a Barry Allen from another
earth in the multiverse that we haven't
met yet in number one we'll meet the new
version of the reverse-flash so there's
a couple reasons why I think this is
important but also because this season
is all about legacy in the hundreds
episode is a big love letter to the
comics I think we'll see versions of all
of Barry's greatest villains comeback
like Barry Allen this is your life so
that means zoom Sabbat are the rows just
a big retrospective on his life flash
museum style like this is your legacy
everything the flash has ever done every
villain he's ever faced every member of
the flash family featured either in the
flash museum or in some vision the Barry
of the future but here we go if you're a
big comic book fan you kind of know
where I'm going with this double bonus
the curator of the flash Museum as of DC
rebirth is none other than a younger
version of eobard thawne I wonder what
face I'll be wearing next time we meet
the new backstory for eobard thawne as
of flash rebirth in the last couple of
years is that he actually worked at the
flash Museum and that's part of the way
that he fell in love with the idea of
Barry Allen and wanted to be like him
then eventually Barry came to the Future
on accident they met each other and he
went back to his time and it was sort of
the tipping point for you Bart on to
start going nuts so eventually he became
the reverse-flash but that all started
because he spent all of his time
curating at the flash Museum being in
love with all things flash remember the
villain cicada - this is really
important the idea of legacy his story
is that he's all about punishing
metahumans because he believes that
they're the cause of all the world's
problems not the solution like
flashpoint style Barry causes a lot of
his own problems there's a lot of
collateral damage you saw in the teaser
where he's walking through that empty
house at night with all the little dolls
in the background in the newscast of
Barry saving the city from the thinker's
satellite as if maybe cicadas daughter
was collateral damage during one of
Barry saves
Hey
so he blames him for the death of his
daughter the parallel being the Berry's
daughter his own legacy is alive and
well in present-day causing her own
problems so when the producers say the
season is all about legacy Nora is the
good expression of that like we're so
pumped about all the awesome stuff she's
gonna do because she was inspired by
Berry's legacy as the flash but on the
other side of that coin cicada will
probably shove his dead daughter's bones
metaphorically in Barry's face and say
something like this is your legacy flash
death and destruction this is all you
bring is it from his perspective Barry's
the villain of the story and he needs to
be stopped
if you're big Game of Thrones fans they
did a version of this during season four
with Daenerys as character so she
conquers marine and all of slavers Bay
with her dragons she's freed all these
slaves and she's riding high like oh
look at how much better that I've made
things I'm the hero of this story but
dragons are also a big part of her
legacy they're our weapon of mass
destruction
so drogon just out on a normal day
hunting for his lunch kills a bunch of
ghosts because they taste awesome but
there's a shepherd's son that gets
caught in the fire burns to death so the
shepherd brings his bones to Daenerys
and she's questioned with her legacy
like is my legacy death and destruction
like that of my father because her
father the Mad King was known for
burning people alive and people thought
that he was the villain of the story so
Daenerys is wondering whether she's the
villain of the story or whether she's
the hero so just expect a version of
that to play out with Barry in cicada
this season so if I didn't say it in my
video a couple days ago cicada is
actually being played by Chris Klein
from the American Pie series he's done
some other stuff but that's just the
most notable thing that he's been in but
let me know in the comments what are all
your predictions for the Flash's
hundredth episode there was a new panel
for Game of Thrones Season eight in the
prequel series so I'll do a breakdown
video of that they said a whole bunch of
stuff so that should post in the next
couple of hours congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner no honor please
email me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here to rewatch that season 5 trailer
and click here to rewatch all the big DC
movie trailers thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome see
tonight
[Music]